the consequences of climate change are
becoming all too clear
but who should be trying to tackle it
to discuss the issue the economist's
deputy executive editor sasha nauter was
joined by environment editor katrine
breit
and briefings editor oliver morton
[Music]
ollie can you just help frame this a
little bit
when it comes to who needs to do what
how do you think about responsibility
for action between
governments
businesses and and individuals or
perhaps you think of other players as
well it's just sort of the the meta
division there who's responsible for
what i'm primarily a government's guy um
governments are especially democratic
governments and governments we elect to
do things that need to be done in the
public sphere um you can have and indeed
the economy we do have vibrant debates
about what the role of a company should
be
but it's not clear to me that there's
anyone that there's anything like a
settled opinion that the role of the
company is to make the world better
regardless whereas um in terms of
securing the long-term future of its
citizens and its future citizens that's
something that countries are meant to do
are there any countries that are leading
the way that this specific you know
showing how it can be done sweden sweden
is doing reasonably well um
but no one is doing brilliantly so the
uk is doing quite well in terms of its
promises
definitely needs to start walking the
walk as well as talking the talk the
great thing about politics is it's a way
to get people from different points of
view and with different agendas to agree
on some things that they want to get
done and that i think has to be the
model for climate change action against
climate change in democratic countries
governments have done a huge amount to
make solar power especially the german
government to make solar power cheaper
it would not have become cheaper without
government subsidies in really quite
eye-watering amounts if you're if if
you're german
the idea that governments can just get
out of the way
yes a lot of good people of goodwill
will um uh will buy themselves uh solar
panels and they may even if they're a
very good will take a capital hit on
doing so but they're absolutely not but
that's not going to be everybody this is
the problem if you rely on the people of
goodwill you're effectively putting a
tax on people of good will and everyone
else says well the people of goodwill
are doing all that and then it doesn't
get done and what you want to see
is sharp reductions in carbon dioxide
emissions coupled to
vibrant economic growth that's what you
want because if you can't get those two
things together it's going to be really
really hard to get either one of them
separately what can private companies do
what is their role particularly
companies that have high carbon carbon
footprints
to see the writing on the wall
the the signal is very clear right the
the future is not in fossil fuels and
you have to be completely blindsided
these days to think that the future is
in fossil fuels and to be honest even
the heads of even the ceos of major
fossil fuel companies know this this is
going to be a transition towards a low
carbon economy and um if you
take
uh say corporate social responsibility
seriously
then don't make it a
a little tagline on the side and
actually
make mainstream that into the strategy
of the company the other important thing
companies can do is come up with ideas
that governments will never come up with
for things that people might want to
consume that will be better for the
planet than the things that they are
currently consuming one of the great
examples of this
is tesla and
i can go toe-to-toe with many people on
criticisms and
of elon musk but the basic insight that
by making a car in a niche market that
was better than the other cars in that
market and was also electric would allow
him to grow both a small amount of
market share but a lot of technological
know-how and manufacturing understanding
and a spectacular stock market
capitalization and thus push him into
more and more um
cheaper cars or moderately cheaper cars
and really changed the way that much of
the rest of the industry thought about
electric cars because having a company
that put them at the center of
a high value business was very different
from like having them as the weird
futuristic thing that you do on the
fringe and so a company that can come in
and disrupt an old market with something
that's genuinely climate positive um
that's that's what we really really look
to the private sector for
another example that doesn't get
mentioned much is microsoft right so
microsoft is one of these countries that
companies that has set a net zero target
for itself etc but what what's
completely different in microsoft's net
zero target is that they are proposing
to not just be net zero between say
today and i can't remember exactly the
date but
some decades down the line but actually
net zero over its entire history we've
got governments we've got companies but
what about just us i mean
just before this call actually i had a
fight with my husband over how important
it was to switch the lights off i think
in the grand scheme of things it's not
that important he thinks it's very
important because it's something i can
control i'd like the two of you to set
that right but personal responsibility
what can i personally do
i think that most of us forget that we
have more leverage than just what
happens within the four walls of our
house if you are a ceo if you are a
farmer and
um you are part of a wider agricultural
system um if you work in the oil sector
if you have a
solar
power plant somewhere um ask yourself
what you can do professionally
and then i think your personal influence
becomes much greater
people
um have uh
have an exaggerated view of how prompt
and how personal the threats due to
climate change are the important thing
about climate change it's really that
it's going to
hurt
harm kill a lot of people mostly in poor
countries and the other thing to
remember is it's not going to destroy
the planet it's just going to hurt
humans and you have to think primarily
although it comes out of environmental
concern the reason for climate action is
deeply humanitarian that you want to
make sure that fewer people get hurt
than would otherwise happen
hi that was part of the digital event
produced exclusively for subscribers to
the economist if you'd like to watch the
full conversation please click the link
you'll just have to register with the
economist if you haven't already or you
can subscribe to enjoy all of our
journalism thanks for watching